حسنًا ، رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الآن
في يومه الثاني من العزلة بعد أن
ثبتت إصابته بفيروس كورونا
وفقًا لوزير الأعمال ،
يواصل رئيس الوزراء قيادة
استجابة بريطانيا لفيروس كورونا
من الأمام ، تلك كانت كلماته من
الأمام ومضى إلى  يقول إنه لا توجد
ثغرات في الحكومة التي تقدم
بوضوح الرسالة هنا إلى الشعب البريطاني
أنه على الرغم من حقيقة أنه ليس فقط
رئيس الوزراء قد ثبتت
إصابته بفيروس كورونا ، لكن ثبت أن وزير الصحة
أثبت أن كبير المسؤولين الطبيين في إنجلترا موجود
الآن  العزل لأنه يعاني من
أعراض الفيروس وكذلك
الإعلان يوم السبت عن أن
وزير الدولة لشؤون اسكتلندا
لديه الآن أيضًا علامات على فيروس كورونا هو
نفسه يقوم بالعزل ، لكن الحكومة
هنا تضاعف جهودها
لمكافحة ما يحدث وتقدم المساعدة
للشركات لمنعها من الدخول
بسهولة في الإفلاس خلال هذه
الفترة ، هناك عمل جديد
كما وضعت تدابير الدعم المالي الجديدة
اليوم مرفقًا للاختبار
لعمال الخدمات الصحية الذين أقيموا في ساحة
انتظار للسيارات في مدينة ملاهي في
ضواحي لندن حتى
يتمكن العاملون في خدمة الصحة الوطنية التابعة لـ NHS من
اختبارهم ، لكن الحكومة
تتعرض لانتقادات شديدة  من قبل مجلة طبية رائدة
في المملكة المتحدة The Lancet ، رئيس
التحرير يكتبون أن
استجابة الحكومة كانت
كارثة وفشلت لأنها
لم تتبع إرشادات منظمة الصحة
العالمية لاختبار الاختبار ،
واختبار الإحصائيات اليوم
معدل الوفيات يرتفع بمعدل أعلى
من الأمس ، حيث توفي 34٪ 1019
شخصًا الآن بسبب فيروس كورونا
في المملكة المتحدة ، وهذه زيادة ملحوظة
خلال يوم الجمعة ،
لكن هذه الأرقام هي ما كانت
تتوقعه الحكومة أنها كانت تتوقع ارتفاعًا سريعًا
لا تزال رسالتهم موجهة
للجمهور البقاء في المنزل ما لم يكن من
الضروري للغاية الخروج
بوضوح كان هناك زيادة كبيرة في
الوفيات اليوم وكل حالة وفاة
مأساوية وبالطبع نحن بحاجة إلى بذل كل
ما في وسعنا لضمان عدم
خسارة أرواح أحبائهم بسبب هذا
الفيروس الرهيب ولكن تكافؤ سيدي باتريك أعتقد
أن كبير المستشارين العلميين
للحكومة قال  في الآونة الأخيرة ، إذا تمكنا من الحفاظ على
ذلك أقل من 20000 ، فسنكون قد أبلينا بلاءً
حسنًا في هذا الوباء ، إنه مبكر في
الوقت الحالي والعلماء الذين
يعملون مع الحكومة لنمذجة ما
يمكن أن نتوقعه يعدلون بالطبع
تنبؤاتهم الآن عندما نبدأ في رؤية
الواقع  من الوباء في المملكة المتحدة
وسط جائحة
مشلولة للزوج والزوجة ، لقد
وجد كل من ركب البريد وجانيكا التجريبي عملاً غرضًا أكبر عدد ممكن من موظفي NHS
، فقد
أصبحت أيامهم موجة من النشاط لتحميل
وجبات الطعام من المنزل ، لقد حصلت على شيء لنا
سيدي ، ثم يقود سيارتك في المطاعم المحلية
مثل هذا المقهى الإيطالي المتشوق للتبرع
بالوجبات الساخنة أو بيع البراغي لتحقيق
القليل من الربح في وقت يكون فيه
العمل متوقفًا
يا صديقي ، شكرًا لك  الكثير من الاندفاع من
مكان إلى آخر يخبرنا الزوجان أن
الأمر بدأ قبل أكثر من أسبوع بقليل عندما طلب أحد
الأصدقاء والممرضين من الزوجين
ترك بعض الوجبات الخفيفة
المستوحاة من الاستجابة التي أنشأها الزوجان
حسابًا للتمويل الجماعي بعد تسعة أيام
قاموا بتربيته  ما يقرب من 45 ألف
دولار أمريكي لمجموعتهم تسمى
NHS الحرجة ، والآن يقدمون مئات
الوجبات مرتين في اليوم ، وقد انضم المزيد من المتطوعين
إلى Antoine Watteau ويعترف بأن
هناك مخاطر ، لكن من الضروري
أن تذهب الوجبات إلى الموظفين في
مستشفى Saint George كواحد من  أربعة
مراكز صدمات فقط في لندن تستعد
لزيادة متوقعة في 19 حالة مشتركة ،
لذا لا يُسمح لنا بالتصوير في
أرض المستشفى وهذا لأن
القيود تتغير كل ساعة ،
ما هو المفتاح هو منع موظفي NHS من
التعرض مثل المستشفى  أصبحوا
مرتبكين لديهم رسالة واحدة
للجمهور البقاء في المنزل إنقاذ الأرواح
خارج المدخل الرئيسي أنا جوهان الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركة سانت.  تخبرنا مؤسسة مستشفى جورج الخيرية أن
العديد من الممرضات ليس لديهم الوقت لشراء
الطعام ، ومن الواضح أن المستشفى مشغول ، فإن الموظفين
مشغولون ، إنه وقت صعب
للبلد ولكن الجميع يبذلون قصارى جهدهم
في الجنة المذهلة في
صدرهم.  جورج هي مدرسة رائعة
ونحن نقدر حقًا كل
الدعم الذي نحصل عليه هنا ، كما التقينا أيضًا
بطالبة الطب في السنة الأولى
ميلي كليمنتس التي أتت لتسليم
بعض السندويشات ، فمن المخيف الاعتقاد
بأنني لو كنت
أكبر بأربع سنوات  أكثر مما كنت سأكون جزءًا من
الأطباء الذين يعالجون هذا الأمر الآن ، إنه
يريد دائمًا المساعدة بأي طريقة ممكنة بالنسبة
للكثيرين هنا ، وهذا يعني دعم
الطاقم الطبي في الخطوط الأمامية في البلاد
وهم يستعدون لمعركة من المؤكد أنها
ستتحدى حتى أكثر سام
عبد العزيز سي إن إن لندن استعدادًا